regina rode her bike two and one-fourth
miles from her house to school and then
one in five eight miles to her friend's
house how many miles did regina ride in
total so if she first rode two and
one-fourth miles
two and one-fourth miles and then she
rode one and five-eighths miles and then
she ran rode one and five-eighths miles
so the sum is the total of or the total
number of miles she rode so to take this
sum we've seen that we can add the whole
number parts because this is really the
same thing as 2 plus 1 4 plus 1 plus 5
8. so we can just switch the order if
you if you want to view it that way so
we can add the 2 plus the 1 first and
then we get let me do that here so 2
plus the 1 you get 3 and then we need to
add the 1 4 plus 5 8.
so plus 1 4
plus 5 8
and to add these two fractions we have
to find the least common multiple
of four and eight that'll be our new
denominator and
well the
four is divisible into
sorry eight is divisible by both eight
and four so that is the least common
multiple of four and eight so our common
denominator will be eight
will be eight
will be eight obviously five eighths
will still be five eighths now to go
from a denominator four to eight you
have to multiply the denominator by 2 so
we also need to multiply the numerator
by 2. so 1 times 2 is 2 and of course we
still have this 3 out there
so 2 and 1 4 plus 1 and 5 8 is the same
thing as this right here and this is
equal to we have our three and then with
the plus
plus and then over eight
we add the two plus five
we have seven eighths so this is going
to be equal to
three and 7 8 miles she rode a total of
3 and 7 8 miles now i want to make one
thing very clear so far when we've been
adding these mixed numbers the fraction
part always ended up as a proper
fraction the numerator was smaller than
the denominator but i want to do a quick
example to show you what do you do when
the numerator is not smaller than the
denominator so let's say we had 1 and
1 and 5 8
plus
2 and
2 and i don't know two and
four over eight so if you add just the
whole number of parts one plus two you
get three
plus five eighths
plus four eighths
five eighths plus four eighths is nine
8. so you get 3 plus 9 8. now it'd be
really strange to just say okay that's
that's the same thing as 3 and 9 8
because you have a mixed number with a
whole number and an improper fraction if
you're going through the trouble making
it a mixed number the fraction better be
a proper fraction
so what you need to do is rewrite 9 8
and we know that 9 8 is the same thing
9 8 is the same thing as 1 and 1 8 right
8 goes into 9 one time with 1 left over
so it's 1 and 1 8. so this is the same
thing as 3
plus 1 and 1 8. so now we can add the
whole number of parts 3 plus 1 is equal
to 4 and then you have your 1 8 over
there 4 and 1 8. i just want to give you
that special circumstance when your
fraction part ends up improper